you are not allowed on this and today
I'm here with my lovely boyfriend
forever and together we're gonna play
wacky backy
no it's not what you say I think the
thing I'm not sure it's still like Edgar
what part of not on the table okay
whoever loses is getting tweet out with
the other Twitter okay all right since
you are the lady I'm gonna start it's
been a wise as I played Zynga many years
I'm not I'm gonna tweet out that you
just need your fart but I do know that
time oh I'm gonna tweet that you fired
in my ass mouth when she sleeps
no I seen you do that yeah the people
know this game it's like a famous game
how do you know Eric where I wouldn't
touch then don't tell me what to touch
no no I'm not chicken and it stuck my
finger up your nostril but I'm a kid I
feel like I should let you in oh sure
cuz you're so bad at this why
look at that mm-hmm you can take and I
regret this decision
don't blow doing what you dare kill her
don't shake me do I sacrifice Edgar are
[Laughter]
you doing tower you don't know how
towers there you're going done what am I
supposed to do now you can't build like
that if you put two down next to each
other
no that's why it's not me
you distracted me you you to another one
to a t-119a to night next one and then
one more one more one more and you can
tweet through text you really can't
Double or Nothing Double or Nothing he
rules that one I think what happening
fight offenders now one tweet I think
technically and they're lost so no no
you stop I think in your spirit stop it
I can't believe I lost
there's come on the table my table I
meant lord high five in yeah hey PA oh
don't you disgust me
so new rules new rules whoever wins
doesn't get good good gets to do the
dishes because dirt butter is so
beautiful such power are the insides
look so nice okay you're still looking
what's the matter with you we can either
the play without you for five I mean
what I happened
no no don't do anything when it's my
sister thank you no one likes you Edgar
no one this is why you don't have any
friends you need to move your butt over
here and your stuff showing your bottom
camera offensive all right he's with me
you're my teammate here can I call you
Ed you oh it says bride-to-be nice I
think you guys are racist stop it do
something
[Music]
you're [ __ ] you won't try hard I
give you try hard I know I'm gonna bring
you my phone ok ok tie it so you're my
cell phone I'm gonna tweet outside my
nips gets so kawaii-desu your smiley
face yes something weird for you is like
something completely normal Thanks what
well anything I burnt them farted at the
same time while Edgar were sniffing my
bye that sounds like an achievement yeah
thank you
ok what what what oh my god what what oh
my god what
was that an hour to correct or is this
Felix because the kids tweeted god damn
what is either what is this kids Marty
is so lucky they answer to you
Ozzy romantic sexy sexy yeah I bet so
adorable I know
classic lovely lovely true talent I told
you it's a skill all right everyone's
enjoying watching us play wacky psyche
sizing guys life just tweeting nonsense
look like me then at the sky going about
the day and we'll see you in the next
one
attack Edgar attack go fart roughest
brofist Maybach
[Music]
you